he invented the fist-bump planking in
the backside Holly and Zumba
I can feel who is this movie for the
characters mr. Peabody and Sherman don't
have a lot of name recognition with the
elementary school set the last new
episodes were released 50 years ago even
today's parents don't really remember it
is it for ultra discerning connoisseurs
of cartoon history like me who adore the
crudely animated but superbly written
cartoons of Jai warden bill Scott rocky
and bullwinkle
George of a jungle Dudley do-right c'est
magnifique
I love the time-traveling exploits of
mr. Peabody and Sherman but there is no
way I'm watching this new phone I've
been hurt too many times
I understand turning an action-packed
show into a movie he got a proven
premise good theme music duh duh duh duh
duh duh duh but all comedy shows are
much much harder to translate to the big
screen and old animated comedy shows
let's just say you're almost guaranteed
to slip on a banana peel into an open
sewer people forget how cheap cartoons
were back then see how they stand
Stockstill or moving monotonous ly
repetitive ways to keep kids attention
they had to be the expensive remakes xic
off-kilter quirky elements that made
these shows endearing in an effort to
appeal to a mass audience and
blockbuster CG flicks are so desperate
to entertain that they have to cram
every frame with frantic action and gags
I did not see that coming they've turned
game boards loki's Angeles and to
Peabody in Sherman's excellent adventure
new people realize that a Smurfs 3 is
already in the works
EP disappointing in Connecticut if you
have any ideas on how we can stop this
let me know in the comments